well let's let's let's talk about where
where we ended up anyway
we have the story from fox multi-state
shooting spree was racially motivated
suspect was targeting white men
gunman allegedly said i had to have him
about one of the shooting victims
what happens when you have a psychotic
and irresponsible or corrupt let's get
corrupt
media infrastructure where many of these
people know they're lying how do i know
they know they're lying because i worked
for some of these companies i've spoken
with the hierarchies companies who flat
out said
this is what we do we just side with the
audience give them what they want to
hear
you end up with paranoid delusional
psychotic individuals
and you end up with people whose lives
are garbage
going on a shooting spree targeting
white people simply because he says
that all my life my problems were caused
by these white people their bullies
so he just had to go out and do it and
then
when you see black lives matter burning
down buildings and destroying cities the
media lies about it
when you see antifa engaging in a
year-long campaign of mass destruction
and riding
low-level terror across the country the
media lies about it
and then what do you get from your
federal government
you get u.s lays out plan to confront
white supremacist violence what
i read cnn and fox news okay i read all
these left-wing outlets and right-wing
outlets
and i couldn't tell you how many times
there's been literal white supremacist
violence
i mean i i couldn't tell you specific
instances i could i could i could name
tons of different instances where the
left is engaged in overt
political terroristic violence oh i get
it what's that reuters
they have a picture of the what else do
you
what else do you have that's it yeah i
mean a lot of times too these things
that are
that are labeled as white supremacy
there's no evidence of white supremacy
and the only way that you can say that
they're that the left can claim that
they're white supremacist
is by going with this idea of
unconscious bias
so we don't have any evidence that says
you know chauvin was being white
supremacist when he killed george floyd
in minneapolis last year
but this is now touted as a white
supremacist thing the people who were
involved in the capital riot most of
them were what like bankrupt
primarily this is what we're seeing with
i was mentioning this this crazy guy
who's like screaming rhonda sanders
manning critical race theory is
is is fascism oh geez they're conflating
classical liberalism with fascism on
purpose
any authority that is that that can be
used
as an example of fascism will be even
when it's not
authority is not bad it's not it's not
inherently evil
exploitation of an author of an
authority position is a bad thing
but a cop issuing an arrest no if you
violate the social construct the
the the agreements we have with one
another then you face the penalties of
that
that's the thing like if you re if you
read like the really like woke rags that
talk about this stuff
the way they define white supremacy is
like really innocuous elements of
western culture like being on time
and right like objective
yeah like objective thinking objective
reality yeah is considered to be white
supremacy no literally
no but the thing that like just triggers
me so much about this is like growing up
after 9 11
and like watching this happen with islam
where where like wahhabi
islam was conflated with islam and then
that was used as a precursor to do
whatever
like the pentagon and like intelligence
agencies wanted to do wherever they
wanted to do it and we were all freaked
out and didn't know what
we were looking at and believed them and
trusted them and
kind of gave them carte blanche to do
whatever and
this like just totally triggers me
because it brings me right
back to listening to newscasts in 2002
2003
and i can just hear it but you've
switched
out the terms and i feel like we're
careening toward
carte blanche on western culture
we we we're being consent of the middle
east we're we're being gutted
of core classical liberal american
values
this this play from the bite
administration to target domestic
terrorism
right is that they're just going after
they're like we're going after militias
right
what they've started doing in the media
is they started saying if you are a
right-wing group that believes in
bearing arms and being a militia you're
white supremacist
even though it's like ridiculous many of
these guys just are like yay america
now the federal government is going to
start spying on these people and going
after them and bring the war on terror
to our soil that's exactly what i was
getting at
and we're going to end up with mass
surveillance of americans
we already had that and the war on
terror is literally turning domestic
uh right now as we're speaking glenn
greenwald wrote an article today that is
titled
the new domestic war on terror has
already begun even without the new laws
biden wants
and what you brought up about this
latest operation a multi-agency
operation by the us government
it's also going to be working very
closely with social media companies
and their main goal is to id prosecute
and to deter
white supremacy and militia members
and again those are extremely vague
terms who do you consider
a militia who do you consider a white
supremacist we've seen those terms
bastardized we see those terms almost
become meaningless because of how many
times it was used on absolute nonsense
and and did the government specify
exactly what groups
what specific individuals will be
targeted here
nope they're keeping it very vague which
means that they could use this big
power grab to do whatever they want and
that's exactly what they did with 911
they used this whole war on terror
objective to go after the american
people they set up the infrastructure
they set up the jails they set up the
cameras they set up the gun pointed at
the american people
and now it looks like they're going to
be acting on it and it's it should
terrify people especially with
what the atf is doing as well and also
it makes you glad that mitch mcconnell
kept merrick garland out of the supreme
court because he's going to be out as
soon as biden's out but if he was in the
supreme court he'd be there for the rest
of his life
we uh that is absolutely 100 correct i
think we need
non-violent civil disobedience and mass
non-compliance what does that look like
that looks like
people in conservative areas not
spending money on companies that hate
them
that support any of this stuff so you're
calling to use leftist tactics against
the left
is it a leftist tactic to be like mass
corporate boycotts
i mean i don't see any problem with that
i think i don't think it's a leftist
tactic no i think it's interesting
because
we were looking at this with regard to
critical race theory too there was an
article in nbc today
about how um you know parents should not
you know parents groups are basically
funded by dark money and conservative
think tanks and that's why they're going
after school boards to try and get rid
of critical race theory in schools
and they're sort of decrying this and
it's like yeah
we're using your grassroots tactics now
that's what we're doing
yeah i don't think it's left us though
uh because i don't think it has i don't
i don't think of it as an organized
effort i think it's quite literally just
don't buy a coca-cola i started i
jokingly bought rc not that like the
parent company for rc
is i didn't buy those i did yeah why did
you buy those breaking the rules i just
eat
coke sorry no you see this is the
problem
coke literally has woke indoctrination
and
you when you go to the store you just
don't care and so what happens is
passively i bought rc cola and i bought
a small
business like uh pure cane sugar no high
fructose corn syrup
pops they're cute so there's also pepsi
over there to be honest
but this is the problem coke can do it
and conservatives
just don't care they don't care and
they're willing to keep throwing their
money
at people who hate them it's kind of
hard i mean
honestly i agree with you obviously i
totally agree with what you're saying
and that's fair you know you vote with
your dollar but
it's just exhausting to be so wound up
all the time you know it's exhausting to
have to think about
what and like keep up with what like at
one point i wanted to boycott netflix i
forget what my like grievance was
at the time it was a couple of years ago
no no it was way
way predated big mouth
i don't remember they did they produced
some kind of prop like something that i
figured was propaganda and decided i was
done with netflix and it's just
exhausting
oh was it the cuties is that what you
did no no no way before but
and like and you know you start kind of
like building up a
repertoire of companies that you're just
not dealing with anymore and at a
certain point you end up
just kind of hurting yourself
just giving up and giving in that's
exactly what happens yeah it's exciting
yes the fight against tyranny is
exhausting and i i guess most people
eventually just say i'd rather not fight
at all please
master just give me a piece of cheese
and i will do whatever you say
that's what's happening yeah we watched
our government
shut down and destroy small businesses
mass
print money devaluing our own savings
and then we were forced to shop at big
box stores and amazon
while our opinions were filtered through
the machine of social media with insane
garbled nonsense
i will say living in a in in brooklyn in
a heavily immigrant community
i was still able to shop at local
businesses that were owned by
families in the neighborhood yeah that's
a good thing the pandemic and i
appreciate that
what we're trying so a lot of people are
like tim why are you still on twitter
then
uh look we're trying to leverage the
networks to the best of our abilities to
get people to go to timcast.com to build
a website to hire
people to build stuff there basically
i'll put it this way
it is the exodus we're not going to just
cut off our nose to spite our face
we're going to say okay we will use what
we can of the system we have
but we're packing our bags and leaving
that's part of the process
that's why we're setting up more and
more at timcast.com that's why we're
doing our own original articles
because i'm trying to get away from the
broken system and build something
on our own it's not something you can do
overnight but we can get started
okay so to be fair maybe you don't stop
don't start by boycotting literally
everything on the planet
but stick to it i canceled my disney
plus because of the the
pr the the thanking of the xinjiang uh
paramilitary group that was has the
uyghur muslims i'm like i'm not going to
support that
granted unfortunately to be completely
honest i paid for a year up front
so but i'm i'm uh i don't have netflix
and i don't have hulu i'm just i'm done
like
hulu did something about cultural
appropriation and there's a period where
i was like i'm not going to boycott i
don't care about this i don't want to
get involved
and then i changed and i said look if
your company wants to get involved in
the culture war by all means go ahead
and do it i'm out
i don't want to play that game so i
bought jokingly rc cola but
rc's parent company i believe signed on
to the statement about georgia's voting
laws it's like it's really hard to get
away from
the thing with the voting laws is
infuriating because you have celebrities
coming out and
the you know full president coming out
saying that these are jim crow laws
and if you actually take a look at the
bills they
are merely rescinding the pandemic era
you know allowances to make voting
easier specifically due to pandemic
restrictions
so it's not that they're jim crow i mean
obviously they're not jim crow laws
and they're they're not limiting voting
in fact
in a in several of these cases they are
expanding early voting
they're just pulling the things that are
ripe for fraud
they're just taking more and more and uh
unfortunately for the right or whatever
you want to call it left and right it's
meaningless in a lot of ways the left
will use it as a tribal signifier
is just really good at this and the
right is really really bad at it
well it's because we've seeded culture
to the left and that has to stop
we have to i mean it's like you were
talking about you're making your own
culture
um you're making your own cultural
products the daily wire is doing that
um the book that i'm writing is about
you know how to
make a conservative culture movement and
i have a lot of great
ideas on how to do that i'm actually
super excited about it but this is what
people need to be doing look at gina
carano you know she's out there just
like
i don't need your i don't need your
mandalorian i can do my own project
we need to get to the point where we can
be self-sustaining with our own
versions of products that work maybe the
solution is someone should start a cola
company that's not coke and
they can call it conserva cola i don't
know something dumb and really obvious
and twitter can go create their own
nigeria
absolutely i understand the problem is
that yeah when you try to make your own
twitter network we try to escape the
system and build your own companies they
come after you and shut you down
we started yeah we've totally seen that
we started a vlog cast castle
and the reason the way i explained to
people is it's very simple we got a
video where we're like skating in in the
garage skate park there's a gadsden flag
in the background
that way some young person who's
watching the fun skate video with some
you know pro bmxer or pro skateboarder
they'll see that they'll recognize it
and then when their teacher lies to them
and is teaching critical race theory
garbage and says the gadsden flag is
white supremacist they'll say
that's not true i watch a guy on youtube
who's got that you're lying
that's what they did with pewdiepie when
the media kept trying to claim pewdiepie
was racist and all that
he had a legion of fans saying that's
not true you're lying about pewdiepie
i'm a fan
so we got to build culture we can't just
sit here and be like it's bad they did
this
we've got to do something else so you
know what i'm actually going to
go we've been playing this for a while
to do our own sodas we're going to have
our own tim cassotis
you you call uh these these companies
they do formulas then
then uh they will make a specific flavor
and then send it to a manufacturing
plant
super like they're not very big
corporations that do it that's even
better
and then we're gonna have our own soda
and then i'll get a little little
vending machine and we'll we'll make
luke's
luke's old-timey sass pearl how does
that sound luke or butter beer
luke's luke's old tiny butter beer there
you go harry potter fan right
i was just in orlando so why is did you
do it harry potter
it was awesome it's a confession yes it
does what is butterbeer
they have to put like crack in there or
something because it's what is it it's
it's this beer
that's uh butterscotch and just soda
it's not really beer there's no
most beers on it there's no alcohol or
fluoride in it
i hope uh but it's just um yeah i i
it's my guilty thing that butterscotch
soda yeah
that it was good and the rides were fun
they were so fun
that was a normal i was a normie for a
little bit i had so much fun doing that
with my
we got the wand and we did the whole
yeah that was fun that was fun
sorry well i'm going off topic here yeah
watch
um you know you know people can do it's
like buy books
from uh writers michael knowles book
came out you've got andy noah's book
unmasked
you've got michael malus's book you've
got jack bosobic's book
buy those books so that on amazon they
hit the top of the charts
tell like show people and another thing
too is like on youtube when they when
they thumbs down these videos and the
white house is forced to take down their
rankings and comments
that makes a statement but you know it's
things like that
that's good there's got to be more to it
voting with your dollars is very
important
it's funny when you watch the uh youtube
videos of the white house press
conferences
and there's there's so many less viewers
than there were
like a year ago two years ago even you
know
another aspect that's critically
important is voting with your attention
deciding what you will incentivize are
you going to turn on netflix or you're
going to turn on independent media are
you going to go after and seek it and
seek information that of course is going
to be valuable
no one said personal responsibility was
easy personal responsibility is about
learning yourself the importance of
liberty of freedom of being reliable on
yourself and
and that journey is is an amazing one
you could you could live a journey where
you could
literally live in a pod eat the bugs be
a total slave of the establishment be
you know imprisoned by the algorithm in
your own head or you could live a life
of
exploring discovering and when you truly
do put yourself on this path
which starts with your ideas what you
just deciding to think about
good beautiful positive things that you
could have for yourself
when you put yourself on this pathway
life is so much more adventurous it's so
much
more awesome it's so much more amazing
yes it's easy to sit on your butt be a
couch potato eat your gmo monsanto
corn down your pie hole you could do
that all you want you know it's just
that easy because it makes you depressed
does anybody does anybody watch zombie
movies and just go man i wish i was the
zombie
yeah that's that's apparently what's
happening right now with so many people
in these cities wow
it's it's not easy it's
institutionalized it's it's what people
are expected
to do and when they are in there they're
miserable and when they're miserable
when they're depressed when they have
anxiety
then they they need to buy more useless
crap to fill the empty void within
themselves and that's why i think
there's been such a huge agenda
to break up the family unit to make sure
that people are individualized to make
sure that they're going
to be easily uh pray for the larger
corporate establishment once you break
up the family unit
which is a natural grouping right once
you break that up
you can siphon individuals into separate
identity groups
and then you can work on equity between
groups and then that's how we have
marxist infiltration of american
democracy exactly and that's why a lot
of marxist organizations even blm
officially called for breaking up the
family unit because it's integral
to let their brainwashing mouth get
through to individuals
exactly this is how you do it first you
make it so that you don't have any idea
who you can trust
and that's why in poland they attacked
the churches the churches were very
instrumental
with fighting back against communism
which my family was a part of
doing and and the family unit i think a
lot of people are have it misconstrued
yes there's there's a lot of bad things
but
it's not like they weren't there before
we're just realizing that
this exists the veil is unraveling and
what it is
it's providing an opportunity for people
to actually see the world for what it is
and not become victim of the larger
traps laid out in front of them and i
think this is an amazing thing that's
happening
and i think people are finally deciding
waking up and making the decisions that
are right for themselves
and and if they're not i mean personal
responsibility means you're responsible
for yourself and i think we need to
teach people that more and incentivize
make people
understand that at the end of the day
you're responsible for yourself and
nobody else is and no one's going to
come to help you
no one's going to go out of their way to
to to
make sure you're in a good position
unless you do it for yourself
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you